hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Gotham episode 21 video there's
only one episode left that's right next
week is gonna be the finale so I'll try
to explain some of the stuff that
they've been teasing that they'll
probably deal with in season 2 I also
have some some Batman related comic
suggestions that you guys should read in
the off season while we wait for season
2 to come back careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen the episode yet
starting with top five moments number
five
Gordon kills the ogre to save Barbara
the man was a confirmed psychopath I
mean he made her quiche the morning
after a booty call there's no way he was
gonna survive the season two all jokes
aside though I wasn't a huge fan of the
execution of the villain in theory it
was like this crazy Fifty Shades of Grey
plotline that they didn't really follow
through on and it kind of threw Barbara
under the bus typically like the really
awesome female characters solve their
own problems Barbara never quite got to
that level of the season so maybe in
season two they can course correct the
character and she'll have like her own
storyline that isn't dependent upon her
relationship with Gordon if you're a big
fan of the Bechdel test
Barbara definitely fails hardcore that's
just a way of judging female characters
in film but you can apply it to other
stories too I don't know if they're
planning on keeping Leslie Thompkins on
for season two I hope they do because
Morena Baccarin is amazing but if they
don't then Barbara as of right now will
only exist if she's in a relationship
with Gordon so they need to give her
something to do that has nothing to do
with Gordon as much as a WTF is having
the ogre kill her parents was we you
know her parents really weren't
characters we didn't really spend that
much time with him we visit him I think
maybe like once this season and maybe I
missed something but I have no idea why
she hates them so much that she would
name them to the ogre like the same way
Arya names people at Harrenhal for
jacket hook article it was a very Game
of Thrones type of situation name
someone for me to kill and I will kill
them very interesting idea but the
problem is is that the characters that
the ogre killed weren't really
characters they were mostly props in
human form once Gordon kind of slap some
sense into Barbara at the end - it
almost seemed like she just
automatically deprogrammed so I'm not
really sure how that transitions gonna
go there might be some after-effects I
still feel like she's gonna be a little
bit brainwashed going into season two
the only time I get really upset with
episodes is when it drops storylines
like that like Barbara was clearly
brainwashed in this at the
so so if we pick up next week in the
finale and she's just automatically back
to baseline I'll be a little bit upset
nobody goes from crazy to normal in like
the span of a week on to number four the
penguin starts a war between Maroni and
Falcone they've been rolling really hard
on this mob war plotline so I'll be glad
once they get past it and they can have
the penguin moving into more of like a
mastermind role he's been kind of a
bystander this season that that's why
he's trying to get rid of his superiors
and if you're wondering who to root for
it like the next week's promo actually
positions Falcone is something of a
protagonist he has this line where he's
like Gotham needs a dark hero that I
can't be it's right out of Dark Knight
where Gordon is talking to Batman saying
you know Gotham needs a Dark Knight the
twist is is that on Gotham on the TV
show Gordon's gonna fill that role they
want to go with an edgier version of
Gordon on the TV show which I'm totally
down with the only thing I would have
rather they not included was that moment
at the end of the episode where Gordon
talked to Leslie Thompkins about saving
her first versus Barbara it felt a
little unnecessary and kind of took the
characters in the sideways direction
they want to reinforce the idea that the
Gordon feels responsible for everyone
he's like the most responsible person in
the police station but he is a human
being I mean you know people fall in
love fall out of love with characters
realistically he'd be concerned about
Barbara but he wouldn't be obsessed with
Leslie Thompkins perception of his
relationship with Barbara that's like
high school [ __ ] I think one of the
most fun parts of this Gordon storyline
this week was when he sent Bullock into
that S&M Club it's like a Stanley
Kubrick Eyes Wide Shut moment on Gotham
where it were like they start this pig
show and all of a sudden Bullock just
goes nope not having it that's a really
good example of the show going way over
the top and it totally working in a
funny way I totally love it when Gotham
does that other really good examples of
that or like the Riddler scenes like
when he's just like pounding the
watermelon last week moving on to number
three Bruce meets bunderslaw and Lucius
Fox for the first time let's just do
this in chronological order so he runs
into bunderslaw and bunderslaw gives
them this very court of owls type speech
big organization with its tendrils in
all aspects of humanity some not-so-nice
they layer in this multi-generational
aspect to it where Bruce's father got
the same speech this is really where
they start teasing córdova Alice type
stuff they they haven't gone there this
season but I really hope they get into
it in season 2 season 3 it's just like a
really
see home run for the show to deliver on
court eval is one of the best Batman
comic stories ever so clearly he's like
the evil board member that Bruce is
going to have to defeat at some point
just like in Batman Begins young Lucius
Fox though is a lot of fun he's gonna be
like Bruce's friend on the inside the
real importance of their conversation
that the conversation with Lucius is
that he lets Bruce know that his father
kept a lot of Secrets you know meaning
he was kind of like a proto Batman in
his own right they'll probably rope that
back in with their murders like Thomas
and Martha Wayne murdered because Thomas
was trying to conduct a secret shadow
war against the corruption inside Wayne
Enterprises if you know it's number two
Bruce finds a secret room behind the
fireplace you can think of this is like
proto Batcave he'll probably find like a
bunch of his father's notes the secret
mission that he was on to take down the
bad people in Wayne Enterprises this
will all be season 2 stuff so we'll
probably get inside that room next week
and then we can spend most of next
season digging through everything that
his father did I feel like this is a
really good direction it's like a very
Gotham Academy device where you have
this Hogwarts type mansion with secret
rooms that you just haven't discovered
yet seriously if you guys haven't been
reading Gotham Academy that's one of my
big recommendations for comics to read
in the offseason if you're a big Harry
Potter fan you will love Gotham Academy
and my number one WTF moment the Riddler
hides the policeman's body and leaves a
big clue the important distinction to
make here is that he thought he was
doing the right thing he thought he was
being good and getting rid of the
policeman he was physically abusing Miss
Kringle so he confronted him there was
an accident it's not his fault that's
probably the math that's going on inside
his head right now he was trying to be a
hero and fell way short of the mark
accidental death is now the new leading
cause of nervous laughter on Gotham
there are a couple logical places they
can take nygma and crinkle from here
nygma can continue to do things like
this you know do good things and find
himself in accidental situations and
take care of them and gruesome ways or
he can come clean to Miss Kringle and
they can move forward it'll definitely
blow up in his face at some point but I
feel like it's too much fun letting him
get away with stuff like this just
leaving clues leaving clues until
finally he leaves a clue that's so big
that he gets caught right now all of his
good character moments are coming from
this Miss Kringle storyline so I do
think it's season two that they'll try
to expand on that the terrible things
that he will end up doing will be
to other plot lines and really hoping we
see some more intersecting Batman
villains too like you had that Riddler
penguin scene earlier this season just
like more different odd combinations of
characters here's my big question for
you guys you know what do you think is
gonna end up happening with this Kringle
nygma storyline and which other villains
do you want to see nygma interact with
they've already said they're bringing
Victor freeze on in season two so I'm
really looking forward to a nygma mr.
freeze storyline they're both such
analytical characters I feel like they
would work really well together even if
it's only briefly I think I've addressed
most of my issues with the episode I am
a little disappointed that they rolled
so hard on this auger storyline I mean
they essentially spent almost all of the
episodes since we came back from the
break with the ogre like revolving
around this storyline to take him down
definitely not doing Barbara's character
any favors putting her in this
sex-torture dungeon and making her faint
all over the place I'm a little
surprised that tumblr isn't more
outraged with the treatment of her
character but you guys gonna let me know
whether you agree you know do you want
to see Barbara become a stronger
character if they're gonna keep her on
the show I feel like she has to be so a
new episode of Gotham next week be sure
to subscribe to get my video there's
also a new episode of the flash tonight
so I'll post that video after it airs
there was some really cool new arrow and
flash footage I'll just I'll address
those in my flash and arrow videos this
week while you guys wait for all that
stuff to post you can click here to
catch up on the flash this week and you
can click here for all my other Gotham
videos thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you